the jurgen experience you were saying
that it's
almost a little bit of a relief yeah
yeah it was
it's weird
it's weird to really explain
but it's you get to a certain point to
where people start putting expectations
on you
they start like oh yeah you're gonna do
this you're gonna do that yeah you're
this you're that
to where i didn't get into it for all of
that
i was never
i was never attached to the title
now as weird as that sound i didn't i
was i was never attached to it it wasn't
like oh i'm champion i gotta hold on to
this i gotta hold on to this i gotta
hold on to it no and i've said it before
and i continue to say it
in my head each and every time i was
fighting for that title or defending
that belt i was
fighting for the title i was a contender
in my head
i felt like that i have to go content
for this belt each and every time
so because i feel like when you're
defending you you're tight now you're on
defense you're not thinking offense you
just want
anything to hold on to this anything to
hold on to this i was never really like
that
so what everyone got felt like kind of
started putting expectations like yo oh
you're about to break this record i
didn't know i didn't even know what
anderson silver's record was until like
before last fight where everyone started
saying oh yeah you're about to break the
the anderson silva's record or you're
about to tie this and yo you already
broke george saint pierre's record i
don't care i don't give a [ __ ] the last
time i cared about the number was when i
was five and one and i was about to get
into the ufc i was like yeah i'm 5-1
damn rashad went on like a 15-fight win
streak one time damn i wish i could do
something that great
and but i just rashad even told me at
that point he's like just take it fight
at a time
as long as you worry about that next
fight and that next fight and the next
fight
don't don't add up
and so
yeah it was almost like a relief of
expectations of everyone's
pressure of oh yeah you're the goat this
you're the goat that that's relative
that's that's a relative like
it's hard to argue that situation
because
george saint-pierre was
the greatest in his error
with what he had to deal with the
opposition he had to deal with he was
the greatest hands down
and
you know when george saint pierre kind
of moved aside
woodley was
was that guy
and and then robbie had a stint there
where robbie was that guy so and pat
militich had a stinch when he was that
guy so was did matt hughes and so to say
oh yeah that guy's the goat
that's relative because styles make
fights
because when i was knocked out i was
like my eyes were open which was the
craziest thing to me you know now that i
i've watched the fight over maybe like
10 times
and my eyes were open which is weird
and so people would like
screen grab that and make a fake page
with that as the the avatar and have a
page dedicated to that like you got
knocked out you got this you got for
them to take time out of their day i'm
like [ __ ]
i'm special
but
mostly people that don't have a good
life
it's it's weird if they did have a good
life i don't i don't have the time to do
that [ __ ] how do you have time to do
that [ __ ] yeah i don't know
scroll through that rather
go out of your way to make a page and
and just because but they think that
that bothers me
but it it's funny to me it's it was
funny it made you laugh yeah it made me
laugh i not you know you see the photo
of me interviewing you in the middle of
the day i almost posted that yesterday
that was so
rough no it was um
what an experience though what do you
remember
after the head kick oh man this is uh
i was dreading talking about this but uh
not in a bad way but it was it's funny
to me so
um
the fight is going
and
there is a zone that i've learned to put
myself in
and my coach is going to kind of attest
to this like because i do it even in
training
um there's a way that i train that i
practice to where i try to get myself
into the zone which is is as
similar to a fight experience as i can
be
and
to where i try not to be bothered by
anything that's going on
and
my body has adjusted and gotten used to
this
so in the first round the fight's going
on and boom that situation happens he
hooked him he
hooked my uh
he hooked my legs
and
i'm and this is my bad knee well my not
so good knee but both of them aren't the
greatest but so i'm like okay let me hip
him through
so i tried to hit him through but he
just had great position you know kudos
to him and i get taken down that i
probably was more upset about giving up
that take down i was like [ __ ]
i gave up a takedown
so we get done and he you know he tries
to you know he takes it back and and i'm
just chilling
and waiting for the bell and the bell
goes off and i get up
and uh and i didn't realize this until i
watched the fight back over i get up and
i was kind of smiled you know i get up
and i jog back to my corner
but i was i look at it and i i'm like
okay i know that's where i was at at
that time i was in that zone to where
i'm bothered by whatever is happening
i'm going to make this
be whatever i want it to be
and so the next round i just take off
and i just start kind of wailing on them
and
and so
by the fifth round
i kind of have him in a spot to where
i'm just like
i never think okay yeah i've got to
fight one let me just coast
let me hold on to them and win i never
think that i want to if i can't get the
f if i can get the finish i'm going to
try to get that finished and i want to
do something spectacular you know i'm
like okay we're going to take a risk
here we're going to do something great
and i remember and this is the great
thing about trevor whitman in the
training camp we we work on certain
techniques to kind of put him where you
want him
and and get him out of there like even
in the mass with all fight like everyone
oh the knockout just happened no i set
him up for the knockout people didn't
realize i did the same sequence in the
first round that i did
to finish him
and
so i start that with leon
you know because i've kind of got leon
in a place now to where i
you know i could kind of really kind of
dictate whatever i wanted to do
and so we get him and i get him up and
i think her breaks us from the k from
the cage so we're
we're moving and i'm trying to set him
up and i'm trying to get his feet moving
uh i wasn't doing the greatest of job
which is this is all on me
and and i'm trying to get his feet
moving you see me change levels
and what i wanted to do is set him up
and i was going to throw the punches
that he couldn't see and i wanted to sit
him down and get him out of there i
wanted to throw him with conviction
and really like i did with mastodon and
get him out of there
and so i'm like okay what i'm going to
do is i'm going to shake that shake
right and then i'm going to let him go
but i gotta get him moving first and i
didn't do a great job of that
and so i'm moving moving i'm like okay i
got him set up all right which i really
didn't i shake left
i shake right and i'm sitting in the
ambulance and they're asking me uh do
you know where you're at
that's what you remember you remember
waking up in the ambulance
yeah i was awake but i remember it
coming too
it and then so you had been awake
because you were walking around but you
were still i was good yeah i was good i
was talk i watched the fight over i'm
good i was talking i talked to trevor
you know i talked to you know
everyone i i apparently because you know
you go back and then you go in the
medical tent and they uh take care of
you and all you don't remember any of
that and they talked to me i talked to
my family i hugged everyone because he's
on video and everything
i remember sitting it was like
leon gave me like a 20 minute nap
oh which was it was
i think about and i i was laughing
hysterically in the in the hospital
because i had to go in just to get
scanned and all of that which
everything was fine so it's like
immediately i come to i'm in the i'm in
the ambulance they're asking me you know
where i'm like yeah salt lake city ufc
278 like what's your date of birth i'm
like i answered five you know and they
were like wow
perfect i answered everything perfectly
like oh we still need to take you to the
um to the hospital just to get you
scanned and everything like that i was
like all right fine so we go to the
hospital to get scanned and everything
but i was already good i was okay
i wasn't
i was maybe disappointed that i lost
but i wasn't like bummed like the first
loss that i had in my career that one
that one [ __ ] with me